Qua è pieno di dottori cattivi che
sparano laser dagli occhi Oh guarda
guarda lo sta aspettando Benvenuti
sempre Stories Guardate la giungla giù
c'è il dottore Cattivo che ci sta
aspettando Infatti questa nuova Escape
Room dovremmo scappare dall'ospedale e
Dai dottori cattivi nello specifico
questo dottore cattivo [ __ ]
e iniziamo subito l'escape Room lei
Eccoci qua siamo qua in ospedale ma il
dottore qua fuori è rimasto qua il
dottore Oh ho già fatto il badge aiuto
premio vuitto
Wow infatti c'è scritto qui accoglienza
in francese bene Abbiamo già vinto
l'escape Room perché siamo già scappati
dal dottore perché qua fuori
ciao ciao Siamo scappati Eh no credo che
non possiamo proprio uscire né dalla
finestra né dalla porta quindi
c'è qualcuno che sta male
Ehi curatelo non state qua Fermi Oh no
che stanno facendo
Quindi è meglio andare avanti abbiamo
dovuto fare l'uscita da queste Escape
Room sembra che qui ci sia stata una
perdita d'acqua oh oh sono sopravvissuto
tipo come ho fatto io sono scivolata
Perché Ah ho capito qua si scivola
perché è tutto sbagliato ma non è che ti
sfracello
Sì ok Forse sono riuscito a passare
tipo una pozzanghera di sangue Hahaha
Ehi guarda guarda dietro
[Musica]
attento è scivoloso ma soprattutto non
cadere qua nel sangue Ok ma tipo questi
sono dei pezzi di pavimento Sì Deve
essere successo qualcosa di strano in
questo Ospedaletto Dove dove
hanno fatto le tubature di laser
sfracellata è caduta Oh no guarda c'è
una mano qui in questo liquido questo
liquido verde Vedi c'è tipo una mano di
uno scheletro
cretino e qualche paziente che sta
cercando di risalire su ma ecco queste
ossa Non ho capito e le hanno estratte
dai pazienti
ah ah poverino
Salviamo subito poi alla fine del video
scriveteci nei commenti che voto date
all'escape Room da tra 10 Anche noi vi
iscriveremo il nostro voto da 1 a 10 ci
sembrano tipo come si dice gli
infermieri che stanno portando i
pazienti Sì e non devi farti travolgere
dal dottore Cattivo
Mi stanno portando da una stanza a
un'altra
Attenzione qui c'è qualcosa che
[Musica]
Uhm No vabbè Guarda c'è qualche bug
strano in questa Skin Room Ma scusa i
dottori dovrebbero curare i pazienti non
dovrebbero
piacerlarli Allora qui abbiamo Che cosa
sono questi credono quelli del gabinetto
Io sto stupido è lo spazzolone per
pulire
quello che si prende così no E poi dopo
Ah no Forse guardandoli meglio sembrano
delle siringhe colorate e evitate subito
e è questo che cosa c'entra con
l'ospedale non c'entra niente No
Matrix Cioè
tutta una stanza con tanti laser verdi
forse si sono lasciati far prendere un
po' la mano da Ah di queste Escape Room
dell'ospedale
qua c'è il dottore Cattivo che ci sta
guardando e Qua è pieno di dottori
cattivi che sparano laser dagli occhi
aiuto Piano piano
no
attenzione Io sono riuscito a passare
non so come ho fatto
anche io Dai sono qui barando c'è
qualche trucchetto No no pure a fuoco
questo ospedale è andato fumo Forse è
meglio scappare da qui quindi
[Musica]
proviamo qua
no piccolo cieco
[Musica]
no ce l'abbiamo fatta ok
Ha dei pulsanti Qualcosa mi dice che
farà muovere qualcosa qua nelle Escape
Room Sì
qualche movimento è lava bella però
queste Escape Room mi piace divertente
Oh da qua un paziente è finito male
poverino
e qua c'è Uh guarda guarda
Il dottore sta per affettare il paziente
Poverino
oh oh c'è c'è un altro paziente qui
forse questo sarà quello che affetterà
subito dopo ma io voglio salvarlo
Poverino Come faccio a salvarlo forse
uscendo dalle Escape Room riusciremo a
bloccare Questi dottori qua non c'è
nessun problema ma questa sega non
taglia Guarda io sono sulla sega Ancora
non mi ha tagliato è vero Qui sembra che
forse qualcuno è riuscito a scappare
Vedi ha buttato tutto per terra ed è
scappa
[Musica]
Dominick cosa succede Oh di corsa No ho
preso l'ultimo di nuovo schiacciatina
dai ma è facilissimo ma non avevo visto
che si scomparivano all'improvviso
quindi due scompaiono E invece questo
qui
Hahaha Attenzione attenzione
Sì ho superato anche questo Stay Ok
allora
ti rincorrono attento
aiuto Come abbiamo fatto a passarle Ma
che sta succedendo qui il pavimento si
muove Eh ma aspetta non capisco andare
dove siamo Ah devi aspettare che si
rialzi su
cosa che cosa degli squali Ah sì gli
squali nell'ospedale certo come no Lo
sanno tutti che ci sono gli squali
fa niente avevo finito tutte le altre
cose Boh non lo so magari potevano
mettere dei bisturi che uscivano però no
gli squali sono più divertentissimo sono
tornate le vostre giganti dei poveri
pazzesca hai superato aspettatevi viva
sono passato Uh aspetta qui c'è qualcosa
che non riesco a capire c'è un buco
gigante Questi sono i pazienti che sono
riusciti
tipo spara delle bolle giganti Aspetta
mi sposto Ma dobbiamo andare qua credo
di sì no qua c'è qualcuno laggiù ma non
fa passare
Aiuto dove siamo nei bagni ma aspetta ma
questo bagno
Forse ho capito vai adesso
si è fatto a sfracellare Vai Rita vai
questa è la parte più difficile Sbrigati
Bravo
prima siamo passati dal bagno dei maschi
maschi
che sta provando a scappare aiutiamo
questo amico qui Ciao amico ah bisogna
Aspetta però potrebbero spingerti
nell'acqua Uh Uh aspetta giusto in tempo
strano che siamo sopravvissuti a questo
segno cioè stasera stiamo diventando più
bravi forse ehm aiuto mischiato aiuto
no tutto da capo questo deve morire
Ok via via aspetta no
Ok Ora non devo distrarmi Devo stare
attento a non cadere ci è mancato poco
ma che cavolo Uffa ci stai riuscendo
sono passato non so adesso dove andare
dai che ce la fai proviamo qua Ok
salvato
medicine
medicine letali Guarda questa è facile
c'è un dottore gigante qui che sta che
sta Oh no stavo girando
la testa aiuto
Non ho aperto le braccia e mi ha
spiaccicato il muro
non ho capito dobbiamo passare prima che
giri come la trottola via veloce veloce
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto che c'è Ci sono
altri dottori giganti Qui almeno un
altro gigante che questo ci vuole far
cadere nella lava aspetta
no
Luca c'eri tu in mezzo
Ciao Rita Io vado avanti a prendere in
mezzo ciao ciao ciao
ho preso uno contrassegno hai vinto il
premio capo
un capo ma quindi forse era tipo un
badge intermedio Forse perché sei
simpatico
siamo andati dentro la spazzatura qui
Aspetta dobbiamo scendere giù
c'è qualcosa
colori giganti
e qualcuno li ha messi lì forse
Vitale
aiuto coccodrillo coccodrillo via via
via Ok
saliamo su mancano pochi stage attento
Siamo a metà strada devo prendere prima
io il peggio prima io
dove sarà il peggio No
dov'è Dov'è l'ho preso io uffa
Oh yeah ha preso vincitore
è un tappeto per ballare oh yeah per
volare
dai proviamo pure le Skip Room facciamo
la rivincita vediamo che cosa c'è qua
allora che cosa abbiamo non premere il
bottone scuola
e questo non lo so che cos'è E questo
non lo so che cos'è proviamo non premere
il bottone Vediamo cosa succede Ecco il
bottone qua Allora dici di non premere
il bottone ma forse l'obiettivo del
gioco a prendere il bottone No sto
tipolando perché sono morto senza motivo
e Vabbè io vado a prendere il bottone
perché sono curioso ma c'è scritto non
premere il bottone che è successo È
scomparso tutto abbiamo premuto il
bottone quindi sta succedendo qualcosa
no è tutto bene
Ho vinto il premio voi avete giocato
questo gioco Wow Sembra così facile
Ok ho premuto di nuovo il bottone Ah
ogni volta che premi il bottone a fare
qualcosa di nuovo
ne volete Fammi andare a prendere 'ste
monete quanto volete quanto tempo
riusciamo in ritardo è uscita Come si fa
questo aspetto eh perché stiamo volando
Wow moneta proviamo a riprendere il
bottone Vediamo che succede No no
aspetta sto prendendo una moneta non lo
prendere subito ho due monete tu Quante
monete hai E una Ah Ah c'è qualcosa qui
non ti può vedere che cosa sono queste
scale è tipo il gioco che esce dal
cerchio perfetto
povero Vitale credo di essermi
sopragelato vero Ok vediamo che cosa c'è
altro altre monete monete via presa Ciao
Anita Ciao ciao ciao ciao
di nuovo il fuoco la lava
è un po' strano da capire questo gioco
come facciamo a
salvarci moneta
non ci credo di nuovo Oh è previsto a
buttare aiuto
adesso siamo tipo in bilico No no
via
favoneta Ehi Lascia perdere una Sì certo
io adesso
andiamo a provare il bottone prossima
Challenge
[Applauso]
attento Non farti prendere Ciao
ti ho fregato la moneta Esatto Guarda
Rita qui ce n'è uno oh no oh no perché
sono caduta
siamo dentro una specie di io sono
dentro una specie di labirinto dove c'è
picchi che ci insegue perché io non vedo
niente perché sei caduta
dietro di me e qua c'è una moneta
Celeste una maglietta Celeste
Oh visto che state tutti impegnati con
fighi io prendo tutte le monete adesso
Ciao ciao
Peppa Pig Attenzione attenzione
scappare
Sì ma Pig sembra che stia facendo la
gara assieme a noi non siamo inseguendo
gara con Pig bellissimo No Questo gioco
è troppo strano Non farti scivolare come
le banane questo gioco
sì infatti perché cambia ogni volta
Eccovi dare laggiù da adesso ti
raggiungo tanto Sì sì certo Come no
Tanto adesso cadi
e adesso ci serve l'anima invece Uffa
dai però Lo sai che mi piace Sì questo è
super divertente questa casa oh Guarda
la moneta Gigante La vedi no ho preso No
sono arrivato primo ho preso la moneta
gigante 65 monete 65 aspetta questa qui
No no fregata vediamo cos'altro ci
aspetta no di nuovo tutto sali sopra
sali sopra Ah dobbiamo cercare di stare
qua
dai Vieni avanti Vieni avanti e passa
un'altra
Esso super complicato questa cosa ok
Forse siamo stabili qua adesso sta
cadendo si sta girando ancora
Aiuto dove stai andando Anita Ma da che
parte si sta girando niente
Forse sono sopravvissuto
un sacco di punti quanti No forse non
sono i punti sono le monete Oh no C'è i
dinosauri c'è un dinosauro
c'è un bug Oh dinosauro già fossilizzato
Forse per quello Eccolo un t-rex aiuto
perché l'unico a muoverti ma siamo
rimasti incastrati qua dentro il
dinosauro o dentro una caccola di
dinosauro gigante abbiamo tempo talmente
tanto paura che non riuscivamo a
muoverci Ma uffa siamo rimasti dentro a
questa roccia di dinosauro che stava
srocellando qualcuno che è successo
ottimo livello eh rosso o bianco Io
scelgo il bianco mi sembra più sicuro e
tu Io ho scelto il rosso si sta
diminuendo sta diminuendo sempre più sto
diminuendo sempre più vedi il cerchio il
cerchio si sta rimpicciolendo
e credo di sì boh qualcun altro ha fatto
la cacchetta
Ah sto scivolando qualcuno è caduto
sempre più stretto cioè ma posso salire
in testa tua tipo Ehi Lasciami in pace
è sempre più piccolo Vedi Sono scivolato
abbiamo vinto credo
No sono via sono mie devo prendere la
macchina Oh che ci fa questa macchina
Dobbiamo finire spiaccicati attento la
macchina di Fast and Furious
non farti spiare non lo sto prendendo la
moneta blu la moneta blu va dai 5 monete
Sì infatti io ne ho 38 e tu 76
ma mi sa che invitare vincerà anche
questa Challenge Ma perché ho completato
quell'altra Ecco e mi ha dato un sacco
di monete e ora dove siamo finiti adesso
è tipo il gioco dell'ascensore ogni
volta finiamoli un pochino diverso Oh no
devo ricominciare tutto da capo devo
ricominciare tutto da capo non ce
l'avevo Perché sono caduto
in sostanza Che schifosa dobbiamo salire
più in alto possibile più velocemente
possibile prima che ci raggiunga Ok Io
ti aspetto qui sono stato preso no
Quindi sei tornata alla base Sì e sono
Non so perché mi hanno trasformato in
noobhaja
perfette Io sono in Altissimo qua non mi
può raggiungere credo perché non riesco
a saltare più da altre parti quindi
per vincere qua vero
Non lo so Penso di sì
ho capito Brava brava brava
perché mi sono spacellato ultima
Challenge
Oh La Bicicletta
io sono bravissimo a fare questo non è
vero Però ci provo Ah proviamo Ehi
attenzione amico amico Noi dobbiamo
andare a piedi senza labirinto
dove siamo finiti adesso la camera degli
specchi
in cui bisogna scegliere
Giusto Allora questo questo li sto
indovinando tutti Guarda Basta seguire
gli altri giocatori
Allora era tutto bene sinistra Sinistra
Ecco che non salta nessuno perché non
vuole rischiare Guardate no
davvero Vitale senza critica e ho
sbagliato di nuovo
dai non è così difficile come sembra
[Musica]
ora qua qual era non mi ricordo Forse
era questo No ho sbagliato
No uffa mancano solo due Ne mancano solo
due non era quello no
si sente
è questo guarda Ah grazie E poi è questo
e poi è bellissimo in questo gioco
No no
fai Non mi dimentico sempre tutto Allora
andiamo dritti
No è finito Che peccato
scriveteci nei commenti Quale gioco Vi è
piaciuto di più Il primo è il secondo
a me questo era più divertente Anzi se
lasciate un mi piace E continueremo con
questo gioco e ora vi lasciamo Qua
quattro caselline su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quello che preferite Buona visione Ciao